[Musique]
deux cent mille pèlerins étaient
rassemblés le week-end dernier à notre
dame de fatima au portugal pour prier
pour l'ukraine une foule compacte même
si le pays connaît une remontée
spectaculaire des quatre co vide causé
par de nouveaux variants
[Musique]
en ce moment les très coûteux jubé à ktb
à 5 connaissent une croissance rapide en
europe et ailleurs en afrique du sud
elle représente maintenant soixante dix
pour cent des nouveaux cas au portugal
près de 40% on en retrouve aussi en
allemagne au royaume uni et de plus en
plus souvent aux états unis on estime
que les 2sous varien progresse
quotidiennement au rythme impressionnant
de 12% c'est amplement suffisant pour
pour prendre le dessus evans une
éventuellement devenir dominants dans
une population ils ont également dans
une certaine mesure la capacité de se
transmettre aux gens vaccinez ou déjà
infecté par le vario microns
heureusement la vaccination demeure une
excellente protection même contre beac
atb à 5 les données préliminaires
suggèrent que le vaccin quand on a reçu
au moins trois doses nous protège quand
même bien de la maladie sévère au canada
on ne compte que 14 cas d'infection bea
cap et bep à 5 et seulement deux au
québec par contre nouveau sous varien
d'origine américaine celui là quand du
terrain le bea 2.12 un ok beck elle
compte déjà pour 6 % des nouveaux cas et
les études récentes indiquent il y 25 %
plus transmissible que le plus
transmissible des variantes connues bref
difficile de dire lequel de ces nouveaux
varien va être responsable de la
prochaine vague on a des populations
donc c'est difficile de faire certaines
comparaisons mais il va y avoir
probablement compétition entre ces trois
nié pendant l'été heureusement aucun
d'entre eux n'est considérée comme une
menace très sérieuse on
surcharge de notre système on a
identifié des centaines de variantes
depuis le début de la pandémie seulement
5 sont considérés préoccupant par l'om
est ce ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal